hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to I and now I am bread
is somewhat infamous on my channel it's
one of the shortest series I've ever
done if you can even call it a series
with the most recent episode of the
world's quietest let's play as a
reintroduction to this horrifyingly
horrible game to you guys and in the
short - to pretty much just two episodes
that I did of this about two years ago
I've never felt more rage or hatred for
any other game in my entire life
but I'd like to think that I've matured
over the years and I'd like to think
that I can approach this with some new
perspective and I believe that maybe I
can beat this game but I want to warn
you guys I literally hate this game
legitimately literally hate this game I
literally hate it but I want to face it
because I want to conquer it because I
want to bury it in the ground and live
my life free of people demanding that I
play it so so let's begin shall we
[Music]
oh I already hate it how how ha ha ha ow
all right let's not lose faith just yet
let's do easy-peasy so I can only assume
that I need to lead if I can jump if I
just hop okay got that grip is dying but
I seem to be doing no that no no no no
just drop down there and grab grab grab
just [ __ ] it okay you son-of it just Oh
God let's just flip and then flip oh not
quite there we go and then let's just
you could grab thank you
[Music]
what did you do what did you do now
don't give me that Gore I have had two
times deafness
that's not words but [ __ ] you how about
those words don't insult me with that
[ __ ] I'm not gonna use your magic
pills boy we're coming back oh how do I
get out of this oh oh okay that's good
all right so where is the oh the
radiator okay so I don't care how much
time I take all that matters to me is
that I get to the end that's literally
all I care about so how hard could it be
you know I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
nudge I'm not gonna try to grab on to
nothing I'm not a cop
all the fingernail clippings over there
I'm trying to make him I'm gonna try to
make a maneuver here if I can well let
me oh my god what do I do
nailed it is the grip so bad now why is
the grip so bad now oh don't don't don't
stop stop stop right there right there
okay why why why what are you doing why
are you doing it and what are you doing
do not let go oh my god what the [ __ ]
what are you doing good clear right yes
how do I give these things out of my way
can I just push them off can I just push
them can I push them off I just push
hands just push them off and I just push
them just gonna nudge it's all I'm gonna
do maybe I'm gonna slap slap yeah
[Music]
all we have to do is not get in the
toilet right there
okay can I make that jump I think I can
[Music]
oh there's Jam there I don't want to go
for the bonus Jam that's been jammed is
that good or bad but now there's shards
of glass everywhere and that's not what
I wanted
oh why why why what am i touch
what am i touching what am i touching
this bad what was i touching that was
bad and frankly I'm just going to stay
away from it and go the other way cuz
you're being a son of a [ __ ] ha ha ha
ha
if I just don't get in the water you're
okay right it's so good it's so
tantalizingly close so close oh god okay
I just think about this very calmly okay
I gotta move fast
oh just oh that one and then right
trigger OH
[Music]
it would've been practically easy and
not what I want to get up oh oh yeah oh
yeah that's how how did you just make
that maneuver if I knew how you made
that man oh why why why okay I'm about
to lose my grip so I got it I'm about to
lose my mind there we oh hey how about
that we're a little gross but frankly I
don't care anymore
it's all the same to me in this
neighborhood Ryan dad here we go can't
move forward parents got it nailed it oh
yeah yeah okay that worked out pretty
well surprisingly no that's not correct
oh there there no that's also no no
that's not don't you [ __ ] dare you
piece of [ __ ] you know yes
[Music]
why I don't understand you why all right
just [ __ ] Jim off don't don't hump
the bottle like a beautiful butterfly oh
ha cartwheeling into death it's not what
I want to do today okay push all that
[ __ ] off push it off push it right off
right the eff off can you just please
why would you do physics like that y-you
know what I don't like you and you don't
like me but maybe we could just agree to
disagree and then you go [ __ ] yourself
that's a good arrangement easy back here
again
easy I'm getting better at this which is
not something I'm happy to say but I am
oddly enough
getting better at this Oh beautiful
yeah okay all right oh my god
[Music]
that's oh that's that's that's fun
that's that's fun that's fun of that to
happen that way yeah there we go oh okay
all right well we're standing bread now
okay okay okay okay all right okay I
think is this guy to jump and get on
that radiator I think why am I not
Torsten I'm sizzling business didn't
know toast
why please explain to me why no toast
I hear sizzles and no toast I see a
bright red light down there Oh what it's
all about
what I don't know if as anything to do
with what we were doing up here Oh
bumpers only you can't reach it I can't
I just I [ __ ] can't I [ __ ] can't
oh god why what in the [ __ ] no don't
[ __ ] me like this oh my god oh my god oh
oh oh please please stay here oh my god
what I what is that it's a power cord
uh-huh get up there and they get up
there and get up there and then I don't
know why the camos being all funky like
that but I don't like it how do I hit
something oh no no why Cameron oh no
now please please just get out there
please
I'm right there please just what the
[ __ ] are you doing why are you toasting
there just get up Oh what what the [ __ ]
now we're we're toasting hang on wait no
no get turned over like that
[Music]
you know what I did it I did it and I
was learning and I was trying to
approach it rationally and I think we
can all say that wasn't that bad so I
think I can do more of that I think I
honestly think I can so let me know if
you guys want to see more down in the
comments below I could do another like
after a long break in a few days rest I
could probably do another one of those
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down the counters below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]